et
bonjour bienvenue dans génération europe
aujourd'hui avec nos étudiants européens
nous allons parler de la jeunesse que
fait l'europe pour sa jeunesse il vient
nous en parlerons avec notre invité
aujourd'hui qui est jean marie le pen
président d'honneur du front national
est aussi député européen
bonjour à tous alors pour commencer
puisque on parle de la jeunesse vous qui
avez tous une petite vingtaine d'années
vous représentez la huit personnes en
réalité il ya 100 millions de jeunes
dans l'union européenne
aujourd'hui quelle est la tante de la
jeunesse par rapport à l'europe par
exemple james toi en tant qu'anglais en
tant que james que tu es qu'elle est en
attente
il ya deux choses je pense qu'il faut
avoir des meilleures conditions de
formation et deuxièmement on a besoin
d'eux pour l'europe d'organiser
l'économie pour inciter les entreprises
d'embaucher les jeunes pour essayer de
créer à une nouvelle génération de
jeunes qui sont vraiment qualifiés pour
participer à l'économie
parce que en ce moment alors on est en
train de créer une génération perdue
voit plutôt que dire on va mettre les
formations au service des entreprises je
préférais conduisons la merde on va
mettre les formations au service des
besoins des populations en fait à mon
avis ça ne sont plus cohérents pour se
développer un meilleur ça veut dire que
post ag les entreprises et les
populations c'est pas quelque chose qui
va rater renom pas la même chose en
place une entreprise sa vie sa mère ça
disparaît les populaces a fait
travailler les gens ça fait travailler
les gens mais les populations et reste
une entreprise ça peut être là pendant
un moment on peut avoir besoin les
populations à avoir besoin de plus de
numérique de plus de 6,2 plus de ça mais
les populations elles sont toujours là
ils ont besoin de services publics
elles ont besoin il ya 10 à des besoins
élémentaires qui qui qui perdure en fait
alors on va revenir à l'essentiel du
sujet ce que fait aujourd'hui l'europe
pour sa jeunesse c'est l'essentiel c'est
fait partie richard mise en image par
hugo nicolas
en europe le jeune se fait de plus en
plus rares comme la plupart des pays
développés les pays européens sont
confrontés à un vieillissement de leur
population
en europe les 10 24 ans représentent 19%
de la population en amérique du nord
c'est les 21% en asie 28% et en afrique
33%
l'union européenne s'est intéressée
tardivement à la jeunesse il faut
attendre maastricht en 1992 pour que le
mot jeunesse figure dans un traité
l'action de l'europe ne vient qu'en
soutien des politiques nationales
alors que retenir de l'action européenne
pour la jeunesse tout d'abord une
politique très volontaire au sujet de la
protection des droits des enfants et des
adolescents et une politique destinée à
favoriser les échanges et la mobilité
insi en 1988 avec le programme jeunesse
pour l'europe 1996 création du service
volontaire européen
il permet à tous jeunes de 18 à 30 ans
de s'engager dans une action d'intérêt
général par exemple social humanitaire
ou écologique pendant une période de
deux à douze mois dans l'union
européenne ou à l'étranger
mais le dispositif le plus emblématique
est sans doute erasmus 27 ans il
il ya deux millions d'étudiants de
goûter à la mobilité européenne depuis
janvier il s'est transformé en erasmus
plus et s'ouvre enfin à d'autres
populations comme les apprentis et les
jeunes en formation avec à la clé un
budget augmenté de 40%
l'europe voit dans la mobilité et
surtout l'éducation une des principales
solutions à la crise qui aujourd'hui
prive d'emploi un jeune européen sur
quatre pourtant elle consacre 10% de son
budget à l'éducation lorsque le dj
français qui consacrent cette façon
alors on va revenir sur ce qui a été
évoqué les questions de mobilité
d'erasmus on va revenir longuement aussi
sur la question du chômage des jeunes
particulièrement manathan kroumen
aujourd'hui passer des examens en
roumanie venir en france allez ici ou là
est ce qu'il ya une harmonisation des
diplômes est ce que tu peux passer d'une
formation à une autre facilement il ya
différentes système de parallèles entre
les universités ya différents types de
partenariats entre les universités
européennes
surtout après le nouveau système de
boulogne avec le système de crédit
transmissibles quand on reçoit des
crédits pour un pur sus et après on peut
compenser avec d'autres matières dans un
autre pays
on peut facilement en principe étudier
un master en espagne facilement avec les
systèmes bologne il ya vraiment une
harmonisation cds credit suisse qui
vient de se mettre en place mais le
problème c'est que c'est nous la
première génération qui va vivre
vraiment tous les avantages de tous ces
systèmes il a commencé dans l'est à la
fin des années 90 comme on sera rétro
1,19 c'est être addict être la politique
de l'union européenne là dessus parce
que le processus de bologne à la fois il
a mis en place ce système de crédit mais
à la fois il ya plus de cadre national
des diplômes mon diplôme que j'ai eu à
paris huit immeubles il n'a pas la même
valeur que le dip que le même diplôme
d'histoire à lyon et ça ça pose un
problème parce qu'ensuite a encore eu un
différend employés des différents la
formation l'intitulé la formation qui
est dispensé le contenu qu'on tape donc
en régionaliser on s'éloigne de plus en
plus de l'arabe selon toi mais je sais
pas si on s'éloigne de nom on s'éloigne
pas l'europe parce que cette europe là
qui a imposé sa en fait c'est des
directives européennes ces processus de
bologne en 99 stratégie de lisbonne en
2000 et europe 2020 maintenant qui vise
avoir des diplômes de plus en plus
territorialisée aux liens avec les
entreprises mais uniquement liens avec
les entreprises et les synthés prix ça
c'est vrai qu'on répond aux marchés là
il a un peu déçu parce que c'est pas une
chose qui s'est pas seulement en france
mais moi j'ai perçu à la pr moi qui se
passe dans tous les pays de l'europe à
l'espagne ça c'est pas la même chose
c'est pas la même valeur qui est un
diplôme qui est fait à madrid qu'elle me
planquer fait assez vie ou à malaga si
on n'a pas les mêmes formations n'a pas
les mêmes diplômes on n'a pas les mêmes
droits
c'est juste que 20 revanche mort blanche
je voulais dire que par exemple moment
c'est l'envers
et quand quand on a un diplôme européen
par exemple un peu pompeux steve et en
france pour le capes par exemple les
certificats d'aptitude au professorat
si je prends mon diplôme en italie et
julien postuler pour les capes en france
ça pourrait être que de ce côté là il ya
une harmonisation des diplômes qu'il a
proposé à notre invité de venir nous
rejoindre pas forcément pour parler de
cette harmonisation des diplômes mais
pourrait pour continuer à discuter de la
question de la jeunesse en europe
merci jean marie le pen de nous
rejoindre
qui est député européen élu dans le sud
est sur la liste fn et qui se présente
donc pour ces élections européennes dont
je vois là bonjour monsieur
ce trait si vous permettez de présenter
rapidement je vais pas vous raconter ma
vie ça serait trop long mais oui on a
une démo sera la journée mais par
rapport à l'europe
oui regard d'abord que je suis député
européen depuis 30 ans j'ai été au début
de ma vie juste après la guerre à ses
partisans de l'europe
j'ai même montée je crois la première
opération humanitaire de notre continent
en amenant 40 étudiants en 53 lors des
inondations de hollande 40 étudiants
pendant trois semaines sur les digues de
hollande
c'était original à l'époque aulas et
j'ai été cependant voté contre le traité
de rome en 57 les dépanner j'étais déjà
député moi et j'ai voté contre le traité
de rome non pas que ces dispositions
sont dispositif économique pouvait me
gênait mais parce que j'avais lu coup de
noves qu'à l'ère guy et j'avais lu
monnaie qui disait ceci est la première
étape d'un processus qui doit nous
conduire aux états unis d'europe
à l'instar des états unis d'amérique je
trouvais que c'était une idée folle et à
combattre et au fur et à mesure de mon
déroulement de députée européenne je
suis devenu de plus en plus
eurosceptique au point de croire que
l'europe est en train d'amener le
continent à la ruine
c'est pour ça que vous vous représenter
c'est pourquoi vous vous représentez
représente à la tête de la liste sud est
est absolument pourquoi avec je suis
allongé ce que puisque les sondes me
donne cinq élus briller
je suis pas si mal placé que ça annonce
assez sur mes murs mais je comprends pas
la logique en fait pourquoi par rapport
à l'union européenne le fait pourquoi
parce que qu'est il faut être partisan
d'une société quand on ne peut pas la
combattre on n'a pas le droit d'entrer
dans un parlement pour des français
vous savez monsieur je ne veux pas
représenter le parlement européen je
veux représenter les français au
parlement européen avec l'opinion qu'ils
ont du parlement européen et de l'europe
en général
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'eurosceptiques en france en
l'occurrence le fait que la jeunesse ne
soit pas forcément très présente dans
les préoccupations de l'europe
en tous les cas pas avant 92 et qu'on
dise que finalement ça reste en soutien
des politiques nationales est ce que
vous pensez que c'est un bon équilibre
ou à ses employeurs que la politique
soit faite par les jeunes n'est ce pas
moi j'ai été le plus jeune député ma
petite fille a été la plus jeune députée
dans l'histoire de la république mais
nous sommes ultra minoritaire par
conséquent ça n'est pas nous qui faisons
la politique et je dois vous dire que
vous devez penser que l'âge moyen de
l'europe c'est 40 sort à bientôt 47 ans
et que en démocratie c'est la majorité
qui l'emportent
par conséquent la politique sera fait en
europe par les vieux qui rompt tu penses
intérêt à se défendre plutôt qu'à
promouvoir l'avenir de notre belle
jeunesse qui devra bien se défendre tout
seul
si vous y attendent et ça sera dur assez
défendre de quoi à se défendre pour
vivre pour survivre pour ne pas être
esclave et ceux qui n'ont pas sonné
comme un sifflet dessous mais dès qu'ils
de tous de l'invasion du monde sait que
lyon vous ne le sent pas nous sommes
honnêtes des enjeux communs le problème
de chômage de la formation de tout ça
c'est un enjeu commun dans toute
l'europe et on doit tous lutter ensemble
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
pensez je comprends vos préoccupations
qui sont personnelles de carrière
personnelle vous allez devoir faire
votre vie moi j'ai une vue un petit peu
plus geopolitis yen si vous voulez le
maître mot de l'avenir c'est la
démographie
l'europe est un pays sous nataliste nous
sommes 740 millions sur sept milliards
d'individus une somme un dixième du
monde et nous avons un âge moyen qui est
dix ou quinze ans plus élevé que celui
de la moyenne mondiale
par conséquent je dois vous dire que je
suis de ceux qui pensent que
le temps va être très troublée et qu' il
va déclencher des torrents migratoires
qui vont essayer de se survivre on ne
peut pas leur reprocher ni leur en
vouloir
en essayant de gagner ce qui pour eux
est radeau de la méduse c'est à dire
l'europe et cela ça va provoquer à mon
avis un changement de population
jean marchera dessus se compare donc
j'ai en chine je comprends pas ça fait
des décennies que vous tenez ce type de
discours sur l'immigration sur le fait
qu'il ya des torrents migratoires que
vous tenez ce discours depuis longtemps
maintenant
pourtant l'immigration en france et
reste stable c'est environ deux cent
mille entrées sur le territoire français
pour cent mille départ et dans les deux
cents mille entrées il ya cinquante
mille européen donc en fait la vague
migratoire que vous après 10 et et
d'écouté mais n'est pas de vous prêter
quelques fois le train en banlieue n'ont
jamais d'habitants dans l'humanité
emballé ça veut ça nous a semblé le
paysage humain n'a pas changé vous ne
voyez pas la différence qu'il y a non il
ya des projections mais vous oubliez
quand même les 250000 naturalisations
par an qui sont retirés de la masse
général des étrangers à leur réputation
vous n'avez vous pas parfaitement le
droit de penser alors il ya la question
l'immigration dont vous parlez la
démographie est ce que c'est ça le seul
sujet sur lequel il faut se concentrer
quand on parle de jeunesse
aujourd'hui non on peut parler de tout
alors nécessairement c'est ça qui va
dominer la vie de cette génération qui
va devoir faire face à une situation
dans laquelle l'europe ne va cesser de
s'affaiblir
si l'âge moyen de l'europe et 47 ans
dans 20 ans qui va occuper de ces
personnes quand ils sont à la retraite
on a besoin d'eux les flux migratoires
on a besoin de gens pour pouvoir payer
les retraites on a beau nous on sera pas
assez nombreux pour pouvoir payer vos
retraites faire subir ces volets chargé
de payer vos retraites bat on a besoin
comme à la reconstruction de l'europe
on a bien dit à des travailleurs du
maghreb et du portugal qu'ils étaient
les bienvenues pour pouvoir contribuer à
la reconstruction de l'europe
aujourd'hui on a si ces gens veulent
rentrer sur le territoire européen
on peut leur dire qu'ils sont les
bienvenus est ce qu'on a besoin d'eux eh
bien écoutez je ne crois pas moi je
crois que malheureusement nous devrions
retrousser nos manches et faire nous
mêmes le travail qui est à faire parce
que
si nous le faisons faire par d'autres ce
sont les autres qui nous comment
imaginez-vous qui vont pas se borner à
gagner vos retraites
ils vont aussi vouloir un bénéficier de
la situation donc qu'ils vont provoquer
alors on revient la question de la
formation est ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui en france
mais aussi dans d'autres pays d'europe
finalement et crée beaucoup trop
d'intellectuels de cerveau et pas assez
de jean-manuel et que donc du coup ça
pose un problème de forme alors je dois
vous dire que quand deux présidents
pompidou avait justifié l'entrée les
immigrés il avait dit nous les faisons
entrer proposé à la baisse sur le trou
sur le salaire des travailleurs manuels
c'était exactement l'inversé de notre
programme qui pensions qu'il fallait
rapprocher les rémunérations du travail
manuel des rémunérations du travail et
intellectuel parce que c'est ce c'était
en particulier ce qu'ont fait les
allemands par l'apprentissage sont
positives que nous n'avons pas fait avec
en effet une université qui est
largement ouverte à des bacheliers
disons deux niveaux au mot vient qui
trouve dans l'université un statut
social pendant 1 2 3 4 10 15 ans la dame
qui a noyé sa petite fille chaque année
pas marqué non non on était elle était
étudiante en l étudiante en psychologie
je crois à la 38 ans répondent oui mais
beaucoup d'autres étudiants qu il ya des
universités suisses et américaines
lorsqu'elles pour entrer ben c'est pas
facile
merci à une sélection alors qu'en france
par exemple il ya aucune sélection
quand on a le bac alors rien on rentre à
l'université et on peut y rester
indéfiniment dans sa statue d'oise if
some tout survivants qu'est ce que vous
proposez pour améliorer la situation à
l'université alors cette question
d'économie générale
si les entreprises ont donc répondre
fait parler emploi pour l'emploi ont
fait l'emploi au service d'une
production vendable si possible et c'est
donc un problème d'économie générale
si vous fabriquez des cadres dont on
sait à l'avancé qu'ils n'auront pas
d'emploi parce que l'économie en son
état non seulement n'en fabrique pas
mais n'en fabrique de moins en moins
mais c'est d'essayer le procès le
problème des emplois les entreprises
maintenant sans les entreprises
européennes sont en train de parachuter
les emplois des jeunes qui pourraient
être créés en europe dans les pays
émergents par exemple le vietnam chine
inde pour la main d'oeuvre qui est
beaucoup moins chère main d'oeuvre peu
qualifiée alors tu attends tu en train
de dire les romains ont peur de la main
d'oeuvre chinoise comme on a l'habitude
de dire
en france par exemple qu'on a peur de la
main d'oeuvre roumaine ou polonaises toi
tu dis nous on a peur de la main
d'oeuvre chinoise est viable mais aussi
fait mouche tout d'accord avec ça parce
que le en roumanie certes il ya une pas
pour ça mais dans l'europe dans une
grande partie de l'europe occidentale
l'entreprise revienne on recrée de
l'emploi et il ya des dizaines des
centaines de métiers manuels qui ne sont
pas délocalisables structurellement
parce qu'un chinois de ne ne soit pas
donné l'opportunité d'apprendre ses
métiers et ses des métiers qui vont de
l'ouvrier au technicien supérieur les
artisans et pour lesquels il ya de
l'emploi et c'est en france et d il ya
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois dans
l'hôtellerie qui sont des emplois
qualifiés à bac + 2 parfois davantage
qu'ils ne sont pas pourvus donc c'est
avant tout une question de mentalité le
chômage n'avait pas appelé à rester à
25% pour l'éternité
on va continuer à parler de la question
du chômage on va continuer à parler la
question de comment on prépare la
jeunesse ou monde qui change donc en
réalité c'est ça j'ai d'abord on va
regarder justement ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'union
européenne contre le chômage c'est toi
jules qui a été enquêtés parce qu'après
on est allé interroger une économiste un
syndicaliste et un porte parole de
l'union européenne sur la dernière
annonce de l'union européenne sur la
question des jeunes quoi c'est la
garantie jeunes n'ont donc on regarde
tout de suite et on en reparle juste
après
jules 23 ans officiellement étudiante en
histoire est avant tout un mordu de la
politique depuis ses 17 ans est un
membre actif des jc les jeunesses
communistes
et s'il sait c'est pour nous à
l'apprenti journaliste c'est pas un
hasard non plus je veux devenir
journaliste en novembre dernier s'est
tenu à paris le sommet européen sur
l'emploi des jeunes est sorti de cette
grand messe une mesure phare la garantie
jeunes en effet aujourd'hui un jeune
européen sur quatre est au chômage
il ya urgence
il y a 6 millions de chômeurs en europe
c'est trop alors mesure bidon ou
traitement de choc
bien envoyé jules enfin bon c'est pas
sortis du premier coup une mesure phare
la garantie jeunes mais non c'est pas
une garantie à une gare une gare une
mesure phare la garantie est jeune allez
soyons sérieux
jules aux quêtes et son duplex de
bruxelles avec le porte parole de la
commission européenne
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi consiste la garantie jeunes en fait
au niveau européen on nous proposait des
réformes structurelles pour que dans
chaque état membre dans les quatre mois
après qu'un jeune a quitté l'école ou
perdu son emploi en we propose soit un
travail de qualité soit un stage soit en
apprentissage ou la formation continue
la garantie jeunes a déjà été mise en
place en finlande et en autriche mais
c'est la confédération européenne des
syndicats qui a poussé pour que cette
mesure soit généralisée partout en
europe
thibault webber est alors rendez-vous à
la cfdt avec une zone euro syndicaliste
qu'ont vécue il ya un enjeu très fort à
mettre en oeuvre une garantie jeunes au
niveau européen parce qu'on sait que
l'entrée sur le marché du travail c'est
le moment où l'on risque pour beaucoup
de tomber dans la précarité et portait
les stigmates je dirais de la précarité
tout au long de sa carrière
la garantie jeunes ça doit être proposée
à chaque jeune quelle que soit sa
situation qu'en tirant son marché le
travail un accompagnement vers
l'activité vers la formation
bref qu'on lui propose des solutions
pour nous ça doit être un droit c'est à
dire que ça doit pas être juste un
dispositif qui profite à un nombre de
jeunes définit comme c'est le cas en
france on 10/100/1000 jane
nous on demande à ce que ce soit un
droit universel et que chaque jeune qui
entrent sur le marché du travail
puissent en bénéficier
quelle que soit cette situation et quel
que soit son pays à nantes la garantie
jeunes est loin de s'appliquer à tous
les jeunes
elle concerne aujourd'hui les 18 25 ans
les plus en difficulté issus de régions
avec un taux de chômage supérieur à 25%
malgré ces restrictions la plupart des
experts remettent en question son
financement
quelle est l'efficacité d'un tel
dispositif nous allons demander l'avis
d'une économiste
bonjour jules en chandelle du coup
l'union européenne a annoncé 8 milliards
d'euros dans la garantie jeunesse est ce
que cette mesure va avoir une réelle
efficacité
on peut en douter assez fortement pour
deux raisons d'abord parce qu'on n'a
toujours pas de croissance si on a des
taux de chômage très élevé en europe
ça veut dire que quand on essaie
d'encourager l'apprentissage ou les
emplois aidés
les entreprises ne suivent pas derrière
puisque aujourd'hui elles sont plutôt
des sureffectifs bon et la deuxième
raison ce sont les montants qui ont été
allouées donc huit milliards c'est
lumière sur deux ans en réalité donc ça
fait 4 milliards par an donc sachant
qu'on a 7 million et demi de jeunes en
europe aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas
d'emploi n'y ait de formation bon ça
veut dire que ça fait à peu près 500
euros par jeune en difficulté par an
donc c'est vraiment trois fois rien et
c'est beaucoup trop faible en tout cas
pour permettre une réelle réinsertion
sur le marché du travail
je lutte a été convaincu non pas du tout
en fait pour plusieurs raisons le projet
initial c'est de faire de cette garantie
jeunes en véritable droit c'est un droit
inscrit dans le marbre quoi chaque jeune
aurait droit à droit à pouvoir trouver
du travail après quatre mois à trouver
du travail voilà avoir des offres de
travail ou sinon avoir un revenu l'idée
est séduisante l'idée séduisante en tant
que droit mais là actuellement comment
ça va être appliqué en fait il ya quatre
milliards par an qui vont être
appliquées c'est 0,05 pour cent du pib
européen
en fait ça ne suffit pas pour
l'appliquer à tous les jeunes il
faudrait 21 milliards par an et la c 4
milliards donc là moi il me semble que
cette annonce elle a été fait pendant un
grand sommet c'était moi je pense que
c'est vraiment un écran de fumée en fait
c'est un dispositif parmi tant d'autres
qui à être perdu dans les landes des
dispositifs européens je crois ça pose
la question parce que si on fait le
calcul en gros de ce que ça représente
par étudiants par exemple en france un
tel cas un tel dispositif ça
représenterait à peu près 2000 euros par
étudiant par an en france quand on voit
qu'en contrat d'avenir c'est vingt mille
euros par an est-ce que du coup ça
montre bien que la souveraineté
nationale que vous prenez temps et bien
finalement elle est là par delà tout ce
qu'on peut penser l'europe comme comme
beaucoup de mesures européennes cette
mesure phare est une loupiote destiné à
amuser le public pendant quelques
semaines quelques mois puis s'inspirera
comme dit monsieur dans les sables ce
sera oublié on passera à autre chose
mais ça montre que la france reste
souveraine dans
la gestion de son éducation ne l'est pas
ce vrai du tout des pays sont de moins
en moins souverain et c'est précisément
ce qui me gêne c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je suis pour l'europe
boréale celle qui irait de brest à
vladivostok et qui serait une europe des
nations de nations souveraines mais mais
cohérente et l'union des nations et pas
du tout une union à ta vocation
fédéralistes qui a prouvé son échec qui
est va dans le mur et qui continue d'y
aller quand même
donc chacun des efforts de l'europe là
c'est en notre faveur c'est pour les
jeunes chacun de ces efforts vous
trouvez que c'est pas bien
l'europe essaye de faire les efforts
pour nous mais c'est pas bien elle fait
des efforts pour nous avec votre argent
on ne t'oublie trompez pas c'est avec
l'argent
c'est avec l'argent des nations que
l'europe fait de la politique cette
donation mais moi je pense que je m'en
tiens à un moment donné de grands
dangers
il faut compter sur plutôt sur les
réactions salvatrice de l'égoïsme
national chaque pays se défendra le
mieux qu'ils plus que je constate
aujourd'hui c'est que les pays qui ont
été ravagés par la politique financière
européenne comme la grèce comme si ces
pays là se vident de leur population et
en particulier de leurs étudiants des
étudiants il ya 10% des étudiants grecs
qui sont partis des gens s'en vont les
étudiants français aussi d'ailleurs s'en
vont c'est ce qu'il faudra les droits de
travail et les stores yeux ce sont des
gens compétents formés qui peinent bien
devellopé son travail à l'extérieur
parce que la richesse c'est que ces
personnes-là forme et capable de donner
sa force de travail à l'extérieur ça
c'est une richesse pour les pays qui les
reçoit je vois que les pays ont besoin
de leur jeunesse et dont ils ont besoin
de leurs cadres mais alors penser à la
jeunesse je pensais vraiment que la
france parce que vous parlez de danger
de nombreuses reprises la france c'est
quand même un petit pays dans le monde
il ya des énormes que ce cinquième
puissance mondiale c'est oui mais vous
savez quoi peut-être mais vous savez
quand même que l'histoire peut-être
voilà je suis souci est un tout petit
pays oui mais vous pensez pas que la
jeunesse que se défendre tout seul la
jeunesse française face à danger que
vous venez de nommer mais oui mais il
faudra qu'elle sait il faudra qu'elle se
retrousse les manches et qu'elle ne se
laisse pas bercer par des illusions
il faut qu'elle sache que l'avenir va
être terriblement dur terriblement dur
et qu'elle s'y prépare à tout point de
vue intellectuellement moralement c'est
très chic mans mais avec l'europe
on va continuer à aller plus avant dans
la conversation mais je vous propose
d'écouter la question de notre
partenaire technique hearts et olivier
malnuit qui vous pose une question
aujourd'hui ce sont surtout les jeunes
qui payent le prix fort de la crise avec
des taux de chômage souvent
astronomiques pour y remédier l'europe
propose une solution
la mobilité professionnelle à
l'intérieur des pays de la communauté
européenne
est-ce que malgré toutes vos réticences
à l'égard de la politique de bruxelles
vous ne considérez pas que l'europe est
la plus fabuleuse opportunité qui
s'offre aux jeunes aujourd'hui pour
sortir de la crise je crois que cette
mobilité va conduire à aller à partir
des des pays à faible rémunération par
les vers les pays à hautes rémunérations
appauvrissant d'autant plus les pays acp
petite rémunération ce que le
mondialisme relayé par l'europe est en
train de faire c'est l'installation de
l' esclavage dans le monde entier
ce sont les pays qui travailleront le
moins cher possible on arrive à
travailler au bangladesh à 40 euros par
mois et il espère délocaliser pour
essayer de trouver un pays où on
pourrait travailler à moins de 40 euros
par mois je trouve que cette démarche
suicidaire mais la globalisation et est
un fait semble-t-il est ce que l'europe
du coup n'est pas leur nomination n'est
pas un fait l état et la mort et de la
mondialisation est en partie un fait pas
fait mais le mondialisme est une théorie
qui consiste à aggraver c'était ses
formes d'uniformisation du monde contre
lequel je suis dressé comme un coq sur
ses ergots
j'entends alors simplement est ce que la
question de la mobilité entre les états
européens fait qu'il n'ya pas une
disparités par exemple de proposition
d'offre de travail qui peut faire qu'en
français aura du travail
baby doc si le français va aux pays-bas
il prendra la place d'un des recettes
des pays bas alors je suis actuellement
en train de travailler aux pays bas donc
tout ça c'est fait toute l'histoire de
l'europe est faite comme ça des pays
européens se sont faits par osmose de
citoyens d'autres pays qui préférait
venir dans tel par exemple des italiens
préféré être en france qu'en italie sont
devenus des français ces inondations
mais aussi culturellement comme ça non
alors ben justement donc cette mobilité
c'est quelque chose d'assez logique par
rapport à elle a toujours existé
qu'est-ce qui empêche cette mobilité
voilà qu'est ce qui empêche quelqu'un
d'aller faire des études en allemagne
aussi les moyens et du coup l'europe
permet par exemple erasmus kiev erasmus
ici voilà ce qu'est ce que ça vous offre
c'était une très bonne expérience pour
moi erasmus robe
j'avais une bonne période de ton ma vie
et c'était très enrichissant
enrichissant pour moi j'ai profité de la
vie espagnole
ouais mon erasmus à seville et j'ai
aussi arrondi méconnaissance et je pense
que ça a aidé à mon ma personnalité
aussi maintenant si vous êtes étudiant
en langues en plus ça a dû vous aidez
moi je comprends très bien ça mais c'est
une des petites réalisations de l'europe
ces communautés c'est comme le sait
comme le service européen 7000 personnes
bon faut pas non plus se leurrer sur le
nombre de millions d'étudiants europe ne
se fait pas en une semaine en une
journée ce soir combien de temps eh bien
ça prendra peut-être des décennies on
s'est tous dit moi je vous dis que ce
sera fini avant longtemps
ces journées change de pronostics mais
l'air a smooth la bourse erasmus et
amener vous parce que comme un journal
en ligne qui l'a 10 à mettre en contact
des gens des différentes cultures et du
coup tu veux pas être seulement en
contact avec des français c'était en
france mais a levé dessalement de romans
des sites alliant des gens de tout leur
report alors c'est un grand rendez vous
et on doit vraiment adoré la route là
bas parce que ça va créer une génération
comme la nôtre d européens qui serait ça
ensemble pour lutter contre tout le
problème qu'on a
l'armée n'a ni porter aussi je vais
travailler
demain en italie j'irai s'il va revenir
demain travailler en france il viendra
c'est comme ça c'est la robe qu'on veut
on découvre brusquement la l'humidité de
l'eau les voyages forment la jeunesse
c'est vieux comme le monde ça ça date
pas d'aujourd'hui et que c'est là qu'une
des grandes réalisations de l'europe au
prix nous ça nous coûte soit d'avoir
favorisé race plus ça me paraît vraiment
le minimum minimorum une petite
conclusion jean marie le pen par rapport
à tous ces échanges avec cette jeunesse
européenne qui se sent si européenne je
pensais avec une certaine angoisse parce
que j'ai des enfants j'ai des petits
enfants et je pense à leur avenir
je suis inquiet parce que je vois que la
différence de démographique de notre
continent
la russie perd un million d'hommes
parents et pardonnez moi l'allemagne est
un cercueil en or ces riches ça marche
mais ces composés de beaucoup de
vieilles personnes qui vont vieillir de
plus en plus la grande révolution du
xxème siècle n'a pas été tellement
lattes la révolution scientifique et
technologique
elle a été démographique le monde est
passé de 1 à 7 milliards d'habitants en
un siècle et demi et ils galopent vers 8
vers 9h10 milliards et alors que
l'europe elle ne cesse de perdre sa
population par conséquent de vieillir et
de s'affaiblir voilà la vérité à
laquelle vous devrez faire face et je
crois qu'on y fera face mieux dans des
réflexes de nation amical à l'écart les
uns les autres
le je crois que le niveau des changes
avec l'allemand entre la france et
l'allemagne est le même qu'en 1914 par
conséquent on n'a pas changé beaucoup de
choses dans les échanges bas en gros
c'était il ya eu de guerre et puis
finalement maintenant il y avait
derrière bien sûr certes y'a eu de
guerre et quelques et combien meurtri
etc rassurez vous il y en aura d'autres
un bien un côté l'europe justement et là
contre ça merci beaucoup jean marie le
pen merci à chacun d'entre eux vers je
ne veux pas que bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode de génération